لن يُطلق على الأمير أندرو دوق يورك
بعد الآن لقب صاحب السمو الملكي
وفقًا لمصدر ملكي ، وقد أعيدت جميع
ألقابه العسكرية ورعايته الملكية
إلى الملكة
ولن يستعيدها المصدر يقول
إنه لا يزال جزءًا من العائلة  لكنه
خارج الشركة ، سيركز بدلاً من ذلك على
الدفاع عن نفسه كمواطن عادي
في دعوى قضائية أمريكية ، جاء القرار بعد
حكم قاضٍ أمريكي هذا الأسبوع بأن
قضية انتهاك جنسي مدنية ضد الأمير
أندرو يمكنها المضي قدمًا في
قضية فيرجينيا دوفريس التي تقول إنها كانت تبلغ من العمر 17 عامًا فقط
عندما  تم تهريبها من قبل
جيفري إبستين المدان بارتكاب جريمة جنسية إلى العائلة المالكة
التي تزعم أنها أساءت إليها جنسيًا في
ثلاثة مواقع مختلفة.
نفى الأمير أندرو مزاعمها
وقال إنه لم يلتق قط بمحامي دوفري
وأخبر بي بي سي أنه لا يعتقد أن
موكله كان مهتمًا
تسوية
مالية بحتة مصدر مقرب من أندرو يقول اقتباس إن
هذا سباق ماراثون وليس
عدوًا وسيستمر الدوق في الدفاع عن
نفسه ضد هذه الادعاءات
وليس بالراحة.  rtable للجلوس هناك
والإجابة على الأسئلة
في هذه
الدعوى القضائية ، لن يكون قادرًا على
التهرب والمراوغة ، وسيضطر
إلى تصعيد الموقف الآن والإجابة ، وكان
أندرو قيد التدقيق
لسنوات بسبب علاقته مع
الراحل إبشتاين وشريكه غلين
على الرغم من أن العلاقات قد
أضرت بسمعته ، إلا أن الأمير لم
يتم اتهامه بارتكاب أي
مخالفات
جنائية ، كما أُدين ماكسويل الشهر
الماضي بخمس تهم اتحادية ، بما في ذلك
الاتجار الجنسي بقاصر في ليلة إخبارية
لمدة ستة أشهر تقريبًا بعد ظهوره الكارثي على
التلفزيون في المملكة المتحدة في عام 2019  حيث حاول
وفشل في تبرئة اسمه ، تراجع الدوق
مؤقتًا عن واجباته العامة ،
يمكنني أن
أخبرك بشكل قاطع
أنه لم يحدث أبدًا
[موسيقى
] الدعوى القضائية هي ضربة أخرى
للملكة البالغة من العمر 95 عامًا والتي تحملت في العام الماضي
وفاة  زوجها الأمير
فيليب ووجهت إليه
مزاعم العنصرية المؤسسية
ضد القصر من قبل حفيدها
هاري دوق ساسكس.  وزوجته ميغان في
مقابلة مع أوبرا وينفري
في ذلك الوقت وصف القصر
الادعاءات بأنها مثيرة للقلق وقالوا إنه سيتم
التعامل معهم بشكل خاص
من يعرف ما تشعر به كأم
وجدة بشأن محاكمات الأسرة
ومحنها ولكن بصفتها ملكة ، فهي
تعرف  أن تضع المهمة في
المرتبة الأولى وتختار من بينها الطريقة الوحيدة التي يمكنها من خلالها
حماية شركة العائلة من المزيد من
الضرر الذي يلحق بالسمعة
ماكس فوستر سي إن هامبشير إنجلترا